[موسيقى]
هي
ليقول أن فئة l'elysée a
كيندا مثل عائلة سيني
باختصار ، المنافسة في لوبان مارين ماذا
[موسيقى]
أظن
و
أعتقد أن هناك مشكلة كبيرة
مشكلة الإسلاموفوبيا وهذا أمر محرج
أجهزة توجيه العلامة التجارية والأشهر
كوداك
لذلك ممنوع من آبي وامباك لها
المحجر من حيث التايمز على الأرض
كرة القدم اليوم ليست كذلك
ممنوع لبس الحجاب
كان هناك العودة إلى الوراء
قانون ضد الانفصال الذي كان
المعتمدة التي تعطينا الأدوات
تاريخية وغير مسبوقة للقتال
الإسلاموية في كل مكان بما في ذلك
الرياضة في معزي أجندتنا مثل هذه العقلية
للحصول على ساتار بوليا أنا
ضد الرموز الدينية و
التبشير في المسابقات
تورادو الرياضي الذكي يجعلها تستحق
تم تصميمه لمثل هذه الحالة من الجهد المقنن
سوف تحصل du nab على ya date ni سيدتي
كانت ليلى بن علي تفعل
بالفعل
يجب أن المناسبات الدينية
البقاء في الفضاء الخاص وليس
مكانهم في الفضاء العام من حيث أ
الموحدين مع الطريقة نذهب حيث نحن
مصنوع من الحب الذي يجب أن يكون كل شيء أيضًا
المنتسبين في جميع الاتحادات
الرياضة لاستقبالهم الوسائل
salimata sylla عمري 24 سنة ومن الأصل
سنغالي وأنا بدأنا كرة السلة
عندما كان عمري 11 لأنه
كان حقا
محور مهم جدًا في حياتي
يتم ارتداؤها في الميدان ولكن أيضًا في
في الخارج كان متجهًا
التحرر أسفل العلم مبلل أوجدة
هؤلاء الشباب في دين هاج فعلت هي لي
اسرع وليون ابنتي فرحان ساليماتا
هو كل هذا الضغط
التأثير هو رياضة المباريات
نعم التدريب تماما أود أن أقول
أنه يضيف المزيد من التوتر عندما
أنا أستعد للذهاب إلى لعبة ما جميعًا
في أيام الأحد أحاول الضغط على نفسي
أقول إنني سأصل إلى غرفة
ربما يجب أن يخبرني Larbi باه
لا ، لا يمكنك اللعب بالرمادي و
لقد تلقيت ردود فعل مثل هذه من قبل.
داميان لي الذي تركه قليلًا
سنوات ومنذ بداية موسمي
لم يكن لدي لم أواجهه
لذلك أود أن أقول الحمد لله ولكن هذا
صحيح أنه وفقًا لتقدير
الحكم سأحاول القيام به في
من الأفضل أن أكون قادرًا على اللعب بحجابي
ولكن إذا كنت لا ترغب في ذلك
اعتقدت أنني كنت ألعب مع ذبابة لا أفعل
لن تحصل عليه
هناك salimata
كورولا وعقد للتخلي عنها
الاثنين اليوم تقدم أ
قتل الصباح لوسائل الإعلام الأول
امرأة مسلمة مرئية واحدة فقط
صحفي فرنسا ماذا تفعل
ثم غير ذلك المؤسف
بالانتظار حتى عام 2021 حتى نتمكن أخيرًا
رؤية صحفي طائفي
المسلم المرئي الذي ينبغي أن يكون قادرا على
يقوم بعمله بسبب
المهارات ولا يمنعها
بسبب قناعات المرء ، يشعر المرء بذلك
حاول حقًا تطهير التوتر
الجمهور من وجود النساء
يظهر المسلمون في فرنسا لـ
لقد دفعتهم إلى الحافة لأن
إنه حقًا يبدو وكأنه ابتزاز إذا
تريد أن تتواجد في هذا المجتمع أنت
يجب أن تتخلى عن جزء من نفسك
ما هي مسؤولية وسائل الإعلام على س
على صورة المرأة المسلمة
كانوا جنرالات مسلمين
قال علم اجتماع وسائل الإعلام أن
التلفزيون هو مكان تقدير
وبالتالي حقيقة القدرة على رؤية الذات
هذا التلفزيون هو الشعور بوجوده
نعتقد أن لديك مكانك في المجتمع
ومساحة إعلامية نحن
إنها مساحة غير مرئية تمامًا
من يقول أنك غير موجود ليس لديك
حق المدينة في كأس على 11 أو
تبغ
لكن صدمت الحبوب هم الرجال
محمد فارا ينفخ حيث هو
مطول واللحم
ال
الدكتور كاتون
خط العرض
الى
ال
منتصف مايو إلى منتصف مارس
المخابرات وكراهية الإسلام في
نهاية صباح موستلات ل
الإسلاموفوبيا مناطق فقط
أصوات اللحظات العظيمة في التاريخ
عندما الجزائر خلال معركتها من أجل
أراد الاستقلال على الإطلاق
بعد دولي ولها
جلب أقرب إلى الأمم المتحدة لإدانة
الاستعمار من ابطال فرنسا
في الجزائر كانت فرنسا بعيدة
تقرير للأمم المتحدة هناك اليوم
كرر ولكن ليس من المستغرب
الإسلاموفوبيا في فرنسا
الإسلاموفوبيا فقط إلى مصفوفة
استعماري l أنت مُعبأ
ضد قانون الانفصالية هي تعني
ما هو هذا القانون بشكل ملموس
خطيرة للغاية لأنها تعطي
صلاحيات الإدارة العليا
إلى المحافظ لرئيس البلدية ليكون قادرًا
معالجة هنا جمعية هنا في
مسجد هنا للمسلمين و
المسلمون يقللون تماما
خادع من أي حكام
يمكن أن يغلق أليس مسجد هكذا
جمعية دينية وهي كذلك
بالمناسبة ما يحدث اليوم
مسجد بيساك الذي تم إغلاقه
د 2
أولئك
الديمقراطيون و 900 مليار
زيادة تان الغرب وأ
وصلت مدة الشاهد التوت
توقفت أثينا عن تناول المشروبات الكحولية
في
وقت متأخر من صباح بوردو هو أ
إستراتيجية
المزيد ل
ال
meinau وهذا هو أنني عوم على ماذا
لدي في مشاركاته على الفيسبوك
يستنكر المظالم التي عانى منها
المسلمون في فرنسا يوبخني
مقالاتها لاتخاذ موقف ل
قضية فلسطينية
بحكم الأمر الواقع لأنني أؤيد
النضال المشروع للشعب الفلسطيني
أنا أدعم الإرهاب
يتم إلقاء اللوم على هذا الالتزام ، إنه
يبدو المناخ في مايو على قانون فعل
حارب عرض الانفصالية لديه
شارك في المظاهرات
دعا الى التظاهر وهكذا هو
هو الخصم لقوانينهم
للجمهورية
[موسيقى]
الدومينيكان و بيساك جول اموا زاراتي
راحيل هذه هي اللعبة التي قلتها لجذعتي
markhamat على tf بالنسبة للجنازة
أبريل لقراءة فجوة المراز
تم طرد الهدم من المواد إلى
يصلهم المستوار بتحليل الدارجة
مثل
[موسيقى]
هناك ابنة بلدي أهدأ
موارد مياه المفاعل
من حيث متوسط ​​الرقم هذا
يعني أنه منذ فبراير 2018 لا يوجد
في فرنسا كل يوم حوالي 24
يتم وضع الضوابط في مكان من قبل
الإدارة الفرنسية تعني
أن كل شهر سيكون 15 إغلاقًا
أعلن وهذا يعني أن تقريبا
كل عام يذهب 10 ملايين يورو
يتم ابتزازه من قبل الدولة في فرنسا
هل انت خائف من التصويت
أقصى اليمين نحن أخيرًا
دعونا نتحدث عن هذه السياسة العامة
هذا الاضطهاد هذه الماكرو الذي وضع لها
في المكان وتم تقديم mapfre oms بتنسيق
على أي حال ، مثل المرشح الليبرالي الذي
سيكون مفتوحًا ل
الأقليات لذلك لا يوجد
تحتاج بالضرورة فقط إلى أقصى الحدود
الحق رسميًا يفوز في أثينا
رسميا القوة بحيث
السياسات العامة اليمينية المتطرفة
يتم تنفيذها في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
يبدأ في الساعة 3 مساءً. المؤتمر و
دراجة نارية صغيرة تارلاي لين لين
أنا فقط أنام المناخ والبنغيلة
مانيلا تنتهي عند ماكرو القصبة وطفلها
مراوح ماتابا روجيرو على دراجة waziers الصغيرة
فارس أو هبوط
ثم قلت لنفسي أنه كان أكثر من اللازم
لقد انضممت إلى مرشح
الدفاع عن الحريات للقتال ضدها
التمييز للانتهاء
وصم المسلمين
فرنسا التي لا تزال متكررة
لسنوات عديدة حتى الآن
ويعلن قانون للحد منها
الحرية لذلك كانت موجودة بالفعل
بالنسبة لي النقطة الأخيرة التي قادتني
لتمرير في المعارضة أحب لدينا
يد كيف تشرح هذا
الانجراف أقصى اليمين لذلك أنا
وأوضح عدم وجود العمود
العمود الفقري للجمهورية على هذه الخطوة و
دعم مساعدة إيمانويل ماكرون
المنامة لنفسه
أسباب في كثير من الأحيان تكتيكية جاهزة للقول
الأشياء في وقت واحد بعد ذلك للقيام بـ
على العكس من ذلك أعتقد أن هناك
لم يكن لديها ما يكفي من القوة
رسخ فيه قيمه الإنسانية
التقدمية التي اعتقدت أنني أدركت
في عام 2017 والرغبة في إغواء أ
الناخبين المحافظين وعلى مستوى العالم
عدائى
للهجرة إلى الفرنسيين
لم يتردد في العقيدة الإسلامية
عبور هذه الدورة التي تمثل بالنسبة لي
خطأ أخلاقي والأخلاق
[موسيقى]
سيستغرق الأمر انتفاضة